nous sommes en pleine crise du comité 19
et si beaucoup de choses horribles ont
déjà eu lieu
il semble que le pire soit probablement
encore à venir
à l'heure actuelle il y a encore
énormément d'incertitudes et beaucoup de
scénarios futurs semble encore
envisageable à la fois des scénarios
optimistes mais aussi et surtout des
scénarios catastrophiques
et même si ces scénarios peuvent sembler
encore peu probable ils ne sont
peut-être pas suffisamment improbable
pour les écarter complètement comme on
en a beaucoup parlé la dernière fois il
semble que jusque là nous avons souvent
pêché par un grave excès de confiance
en négligeant la probabilité des cas
extrêmes y compris d'ailleurs de
nombreux experts
bien entendu en premier lieu il à la
catastrophe sanitaire probable des
milliers de personnes sont déjà décédées
du coronavirus en france et des dizaines
de milliers d'autres risquent de
succomber à leur tour dans les semaines
à venir
à l'échelle mondiale certains craignent
encore la possibilité de voir des
dizaines de millions de victimes
succombent et duco vide 19 pour sauver
des vies la quasi totalité des pays
développés à travers le monde ont pris
des mesures très fortes comme le
confinement de leur population
cependant le confinement à ses propres
effets secondaires indésirables
en premier lieu bien entendu il
correspond à limiter les libertés
individuelles particulier la liberté de
circulation
on peut aussi voir une sorte de
violation de notre vie privée puisque
les autorités ont maintenant une très
bonne idée de là où se trouve chaque
jour les mesures actuelles peuvent donc
être considérés quelque peu liberticide
même s'il semble que beaucoup d'entre
nous soyons d'accord avec cette
restriction de notre liberté au profit
de la santé publique
en second lieu le confinement a aussi
des effets indésirables sur notre santé
en particulier nous invite à une moindre
exposition au soleil et à moins
d'efforts physiques
enfin il semble poser des risques de
santé mentale important et je vous
renvoie vers cette vidéo de dans ton
corps pour plus de détails
mais ce n'est pas tout ces décisions
fortes semble aussi et surtout avoir
bouleversé les économies de nos pays
même en cas de déconfinement progressif
pendant des mois les bars et restaurants
et les théâtres risque de rester fermé
de nombreuses entreprises vont devoir
télétravailler et de nombreux commerces
notamment autour du loisir risque de
voir disparaître leur clientèle de façon
inquiétante
les cours de la bourse ont chuté suite à
la crise
les marchés financiers connaissent une
crise peut être comparable à celle de la
grande dépression qui avait précédé la
seconde guerre mondiale et qui en était
probablement un facteur très aggravant
en particulier il aura suffi de 21
joueurs pour connaître une chute que la
crise financière de 2008 a mis un an à
causer un confinement prolongée pourrait
accentuer cette chute dans les marchés
financiers
à l'instar de ce qui s'est passé en 2008
et en particulier pour la banque lehman
brothers une telle crise financière
risque de réduire grandement la valeur
des actifs financiers des banques qui
sont déjà fortement endetté notamment
pour profiter de l'effet de levier
voilà qui les rapprocherait
dangereusement de la faillite et
pourrait provoquer une perte de
confiance des investisseurs
mais alors si ces investisseurs
souhaitent récupérer leur argent
certaines entreprises financières
pourraient devoir vendre précipitamment
leurs actifs à moindre coût ce qui
pourrait accélérer la perte de confiance
d'autres investisseurs initiant ainsi un
cercle vicieux qui pourrait aboutir à la
faillite de ces entreprises financières
alors je tiens à signaler que j'ai
beaucoup simplifié le problème peut être
moi j'ai pas expliquer la distinction
entre insolvabilité et manque de
liquidités mais je vais vous renversez
vidéo de henry cap pour comprendre plus
en détail les enjeux pour cette
entreprise financière ok ça ce sont des
faillites qui pourraient survenir pour
des raisons purement financières comme
c'est déjà arrivé en 2008 aux états unis
mais ce qui rend la situation actuelle
plus préoccupant encore que le cas de
2008 c'est que le confinement affecte
aussi et surtout l'économie réelle
différentes sources suggèrent que
l'activité économique et de différents
pays a été réduite d'environ 25 % ou 30
% au cours des trois dernières semaines
des dizaines de millions d'américains se
sont alors rués pour demander
l'allocation chômage soit 20 à 40 fois
plus qu'en temps normal
le taux de chômage a atteint 14% soit
plus que lors des pires heures de la
crise de 2008
à ce rythme on pourra peut-être même
s'approcher du record de 25 % de la
grande dépression
sauf que cette fois la transition
pourrait se produire en l'espace de
semaines ou de mois alors qu'elle a pris
des années
lors de la grande dépression ce qui
serait beaucoup plus préoccupant comme
souvent la crise pourrait être
particulièrement désastreuses pour les
populations défavorisées
cette étude en particulier suggère que
le nombre de personnes vivant en
situation de pauvreté pourrait augmenter
d'un demi millier
pire encore jusque là certaines
entreprises ont pu se dire qu elle
survivre est un arrêt temporaire de
leurs activités de quelques semaines en
entamant peut-être leurs réserves
financières voir ensemble des temps
auprès de banques
cependant si le confinement dure
plusieurs mois ce pari pourrait devenir
père dans ce qui pourrait forcer
beaucoup d'entreprises à licencier
massivement a elle aussi faire faillite
et a entraîné les banques avec elle en
france le gouvernement a proposé des
aides financières pour rassurer les
banques et pour venir en aide
directement aux entreprises
mais ces mesures pourraient être
insuffisantes en cas de confinement
prolongées ou répétées et si le
gouvernement continue lui même
d'aggraver son déficit public
les marchés financiers pourraient
craindre un non remboursement et décidé
de ne plus prêter à l'état français ce
qui pourrait provoquer une crise
financière similaire et sans doute même
plus grave encore que la crise de l'euro
est encore une fois pour plus de détails
je vous renvoie vers des vidéos de
ricard en particulier celle là il y
aurait peut-être alors des mesures plus
radicales à prendre comme des
financements directs par la banque
centrale européenne qui pourrait
permettre de financer indirectement les
états européens directement les
entreprises et même directement des
revenus universel alors tout ceci aura
peut-être un effet sur l'inflation en
fonction de ce qui est fait mais cet
effet ne serait pas nécessairement un
problème
en fait ça semble surtout dépendre de
l'offre et donc de production suffisante
des entreprises il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de complexité derrière tout ça encore
une fois je vais recommander les vidéos
d'oreca pour en savoir plus ceci dit
même si le revenu de base est adopté ce
qui semble au moins envisager dans un
nombre croissant de pays
il reste le problème des chaînes de
production malheureusement dans nos
sociétés ultra-connectés l'arrêt
d'activité de nombreuses petites
entreprises peut avoir des effets
catastrophiques à grande échelle
en effet toute entreprise qui perd ses
fournisseurs ne pourra plus fournir son
service et pourrait devoir faire
faillite à son tour mais ça ne
s'arrêterait pas là
il en ira peut-être de même pour des
entreprises dont les clients ont fait
faillite c'est pourquoi il semble y
avoir un sérieux risque que le simple
ralentissement économique d'une
entreprise en chine ou aux états unis
peut causer un effondrement de toute une
industrie en france
les assureurs de ces entreprises
risquent à leur tour d'être trop
endettés ce qui pourrait causer leur
faillite ainsi que la faillite de leur
propre assureur ou investisseurs et
ainsi de suite
en fait on a là un risque de
contamination
de l'instabilité financière des
entreprises similaires à la propagation
d'un virus de façon préoccupante
cette propagation pourrait être elle
même exponentiel autrement dit alors que
tout semble plus ou moins sous contrôle
il semble possible que très rapidement
trop rapidement tous paraissent tout à
coup hors de contrôle
et on pourrait alors assister à des
pénuries de biens de base d'une
nourriture d'électricité ou pire encore
internet de nombreuses vulnérabilités
sont encore probablement invisible même
aux yeux des experts
par exemple le gouverneur du new jersey
a lui appelé publiquement au recrutement
d'informaticiens capable de programmer
en langage cobol un vieux langage
inventé notamment par grasshopper à la
fin des années 50 mais qui n'est
généralement plus enseigné dans les
universités
malheureusement du coup les plus aptes à
maintenir les codes en cobol sont
principalement âgées et sont donc
particulièrement à risque du coc vite 19
là où ça devient flippant c'est quand on
se rend compte que les algorithmes au
coeur du système financier sont en
langage cobol si ces algorithmes bug
alors tout le système financier pourrait
être en sérieux danger et si celui ci
tombe on risque d'assister un chaos
total et à des pénuries de biens de base
bien sûr j'envisage là un cas extrême
qui pour l'instant en tout cas ne me
semble pas si probable mais je me trompe
peut-être
quoi qu'il en soit pour éviter de telles
catastrophes il est urgent de les voir
venir pour recruter et former les bonnes
personnes aux tâches critiques mais tout
ça ça prend du temps
il est donc crucial d'être dans
l'anticipation
or dans le cas du cobol il s'agit d'une
vulnérabilité qui n'a été signalé que le
5 avril dernier
il semble malheureusement probable que
de nombreux autres vulnérabilités de nos
sociétés seront signalés trop tard
ce qui risque de provoquer un désastre
économique qui pourrait affecter
l'emploi des minions peut-être même deux
milliards d'individus sur terre comme
l'expliquent très bien monsieur filles
dans cette vidéo nous vivons au milieu
d'objets incroyable des objets
incompréhensible des objets que personne
littéralement personne ne sait fabriquer
seuls des objets à la fabrication
desquels un nombre incalculable de gens
ont sans avoir la moindre idée
participer aujourd'hui et depuis des
siècles la production et la livraison de
nos biens y compris des biens de base
résulte d'une chaîne de production très
complexe donc chaque maillon est une
vulnérabilité potentielle et dont la
faillite risquent de se propager
de proche en proche et ce de manière
peut-être exponentielle donc si vous
voulez contribuer à minimiser une
catastrophe
je vous invite à adopter le safety man 7
et 1 réfléchir aux cas extrêmes qui
pourrait avoir été négligé jusque là en
commençant peut-être par votre coeur de
métier que pourriez-vous votre
entreprise faire pour minimiser les
chances de catastrophes à l'échelle
individuelle à l'échelle de votre
entreprise voire à l'échelle de notre
société
ok ça c'est le côté économique mais les
risques et ne se limite malheureusement
pas à l'économie
en fait avant un tel effondrement
économique à cause peut-être de la
menace d'un tel effondrement il y aura
très probablement des réactions
possiblement violente mal réfléchie et
mal informée à la fois de dirigeants
politiques ou de partie de la population
un confinement prolonger semble ainsi
poser des risques d'instabilité
politiques majeurs allant d'un populisme
autoritaire à des conflits
internationaux en particulier quels que
soient les décisions des dirigeants d'un
pays il semble y avoir un risque que la
crise exacerbe les tensions politiques
ce qui pourrait désorganiser la réponse
aux qu'ovide 19 une instabilité
politique pourrait ainsi ajouter de la
confusion ce qui réduirait l'efficacité
des appels aux gestes barrières à la
distanciation social au confinement et
aux autres mesures à venir
d'un autre côté les dirigeants risquent
eux aussi d'abuser de leur pouvoir pour
faire passer dans l'urgence des lois ou
des ordres problématique
outre atlantique ce genre de phénomène
semble déjà prendre forme
le président américain semble vouloir
profiter de son pouvoir d'influencé sur
l'affectation du matériel médical à
différents états pour exiger plus de
reconnaissance et d'acclamations de son
travail notamment dans l'optique des
élections présidentielles à venir
voilà qui risque de créer des tensions
supplémentaires dans un pays déjà plus
polarisé que jamais et où la vente
d'armes a été considéré être un bien de
base de la suggérer un risque de guerre
civile désastreuses aux états unis
qui aurait des conséquences désastreuses
à l'échelle mondiale au moins en termes
économiques
il y a encore bien sûr un pas à faire
mais cette possibilité n'est peut-être
pas suffisamment improbable pour être
négligé surtout en cas de confinement
prolongé par ailleurs les tensions
politiques pourraient ne pas s'arrêter à
l'échelle nationale selon des officiels
allemands les américains auraient fait
pression sur l'entreprise allemand de
curva qu l'un des plus prometteurs
fabricants de vaccins pour que toute la
production soit envoyée directement aux
états unis des menaces plus directs ont
été faites par les états unis envers le
venezuela
enfin d'autres rumeurs parfois confirmée
par les autorités de détournement
d'envoi de matériels médicaux circulent
qui mêle de nombreux pays comme les
états unis l'espagne la turquie et même
la france et même si on prend ces
rumeurs avec des pincettes la simple
existence de rumeurs même infondées
pourrait suffire à provoquer des
tensions internationales qui pourraient
ensuite dégénéré
or là encore plus le confinement dure
plus le risque qu'une rumeur avérées ou
non c'est une goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase semble élevé les
mécompréhension peuvent suffire à
déclencher des réactions violentes et
dangereuses comme l'illustrent très bien
le jeu de nikki kahn
pire encore la probabilité d'une
catastrophe pourrait ne pas croître de
manière linéaire au contraire sachant le
risque d'effet domino il ne semble pas
déraisonnable de penser que ce risque
pour un peu d'être croître de manière
exponentielle avec la durée du
confinement plus le confinement dure
plus le risque de politiques
autoritaires ou d'effondrement politique
paraît préoccupant
dans ce contexte pour le bien de
l'ensemble des populations à travers le
monde
il semble urgent de préparer aussi vite
que possible un déconfinement rapide
mais surtout sécurisé malheureusement
ces deux tâches sont elles mêmes
extrêmement as-tu comme nous semble
encore très loin de l'immunité de groupe
il semble y avoir un risque énorme de
seconde vague de contamination du coc
vite 19 dans le cas de la grippe
espagnole c'est même cette seconde vague
qui a été catastrophique sur ce graphe
qui décrit le nombre de morts royaume
uni
on voit qu'il a même eu une troisième
vague cette seconde vague pourra elle
aussi submergé les services hospitaliers
pour éviter une telle catastrophe
sanitaire
il semblera urgent de prendre à nouveau
des mesures radicales comme un second
confinement d'ailleurs selon ce sondage
d'économies
ce second confinement pourrait être la
meilleure stratégie d'un point de vue
économique
néanmoins quand bien même un second
confinement serait un moindre mal
celui ci pourrait malgré tout augmenter
dangereusement le risque de catastrophes
économiques ou politiques
de nombreux plans de relance post
confinement risque d'être coupés courts
et conduire à une rechute qui frapperait
des organisations en état déjà critique
pire encore ce second confinement
pourrait entamer sérieusement la
confiance économique en donnant
l'impression qu'on en finira jamais avec
cette pandémie
dès lors le risque de catastrophe
économique et politique pourrait être
complètement démultiplier ce qu'ils
pourraient ensuite mettre en danger des
millions voire des centaines de millions
de vie sur terre
aujourd'hui l'urgence semble de garantir
un déconfinement rapide mais surtout et
avant tout sécurisé autrement dit il
semble critique de faire tout ce qu'il
faut pour garantir autant que possible
que le déconfinement ne conduise pas à
une seconde vague de croissance
exponentielle des cas de co vide 19
tel semble être d'ailleurs l'avis des
économistes interrogés
mais alors que faire pour y parvenir
pour comprendre le besoin de confinement
il est utile de s'attarder sur un nombre
en particulier appelé taux de
reproduction effectif souvent dotés rt
alors vous avez certainement déjà
entendu parler de zéro le taux de
reproduction de base qui le nombre moyen
de personnes qu'un individu un fait dans
une population donnée miniser et sans
mesures particulières et bien rtc le
nombre moyen de personnes qu'un individu
infecté à l'instant t va contaminer
étant donné le contexte en particulier
les mesures de prévention appliqué à
l'instant t
je ne peux pas insisté suffisamment sur
l'importance de ce nombre et en
particulier de s'il est inférieur ou
supérieur à 1
oui car si rt est inférieur à 1 alors le
qu'ovide 19 est essentiellement contenu
on pourra à peu près oublié son
existence et reprendre une vie
approximativement normal mais si rt est
supérieur à 1 alors sa croissance
continuera d'être exponentielle avec
toutes les bizarreries et tous les
dangers de l'expérience yale dont tant
de vidéos vous ont déjà parlé il est
crucial pour le futur de l'humanité que
rt de vienne et reste inférieur à 1
la santé publique mais aussi nous
économie et notre stabilité politique en
dépend ramenez rt durablement en dessous
de 1 semble être la priorité
notre futur dépend de ce nombre
alors il existe une façon de garantir
une réduction drastique de rt qui
consiste à s'appuyer sur l'immunité de
groupes plus précisément si une grosse
partie de la population est immunisée au
qu'ovide 19
alors non seulement elle ne pourrait
plus être infectées mais aussi et
surtout il ne pourrait plus transmettre
locaux vides 19
cependant le théorème du seuil en
épidémiologie affirme que l'immunité de
groupes rend rt inférieure à 1
si et seulement si la proportion
d'individus immunisés est supérieur à 1
- sur 0 ou 1 0 et le taux de
reproduction de base
nessim pour le comité 19 que ce taux de
base est entre 2 et 3 la proportion
d'immuniser doit alors d'être au moins
40 % mais surtout si on veut vraiment
être confiant sur l'absence de seconde
vague
il faut envisager les pires cas ce qui
nécessiterait une proportion diminue et
de peut-être 70%
or il n'ya malheureusement que deux
façons d'arriver à un tel chiffre
soit on laisse 70% de la population être
infectés avec un taux de décès de 1
% ceci causerait près d'un demi million
de morts en france et 50 millions de
morts à travers le monde
mais en cas de surcharge hospitalière
ces chiffres pourraient être
démultipliée peut-être même d'un facteur
on pourrait alors assister à des
centaines de millions de morts à travers
le monde ce qui paraît inacceptable
l'autre solution consiste à vacciner au
moins 70% de la population
malheureusement pour cela il faudra
d'abord avoir un vaccin mais un vaccin
prendra au moins un an pour être produit
et surtout valider ce n'est donc pas une
solution envisageable pour les mois à
venir
côté traitement on espère bien sûr que
des médicaments seront efficaces pour
traiter des patients infectés et en
particulier des patients infectés en
situation critique mais il semble
critique d'envisager le cas
malheureusement probable où aucun
traitement ne sera vraiment efficace
pour soigner le coc vide si un
traitement réduit le taux de létalité
par deux ce serait déjà génial quoi
qu'il en soit ces traitements seront
très probablement inefficace pour
réduire suffisamment le taux de
reproduction effectif
rt ainsi même si un traitement empêcher
les patients de mourir du coc vite 19
il serait inefficace pour éviter une
surcharge hospitalière le futur de nos
sociétés semblent en fait bien plus
dépendre de rt qui ne dépend des
traitements du coc vite
ainsi pour réduire le taux de
reproduction effectif
arte dans les mois à venir il va nous
falloir avant tout miser sur des
interventions non pharmaceutiques ce
sont de ces interventions et en
particulier de l'efficacité de ses
interventions que le futur de notre
santé de notre économie et de notre
stabilité politique semble dépendre
il est ainsi urgent d'identifier des
interventions efficaces pour que la
combinaison suffisent à ramener rt en
dessous de 1
si possible sans nécessiter de
confinement total
malheureusement selon cette étude de
l'impérial college du 30 mars
il semble que dans 11 pays d'europe des
mesures pourtant fortes comme
l'interdiction des événements publics et
la fermeture des écoles même combiné à
aux gestes barrières et à la
distanciation sociales ont été très
insuffisantes pour ramener rt en dessous
de 1 jusque là en europe parmi les
mesures prises
seul le confinement semble à même de
ramener rt en dessous de 1
même si l'étude de lyme période collège
expriment une grande incertitude y
compris à ce sujet même en ces temps de
confinement les données jusque là ne
semblent pas encore clairement indiquer
une réduction suffisante
du taux de contamination ceci dit ceci
semble largement s'expliquer par les
mouvements de population juste avant le
confinement et par les contaminations au
sein des foyers
mais même si on parvient à réduire le
taux de reproduction à dison 0,5 grâce
au confinement pour passer des millions
d' infecté en france comme cela est
estimée par certaines études à dison
milka de kobe 19
il faudrait en fait presque trois mois
et ça ça ne correspond même pas aux
pires cas on peut imaginer que le taux
de reproduction demeurera élevée
notamment si les consignes de
confinement ne sont pas suffisamment
respecté au quelqu'un il pourrait
falloir de nombreux mois pour atteindre
des nombres de cas suffisamment faible
pour passer au déconfinement bref même
si vous êtes en confinement fait encore
attention à bien appliquer les mesures
de distanciation sociale et de gestes
barrières pour éviter de propager le
virus
si vous le pouvez rester chez vous le
futur du confinement est en jeu et tous
les risques économiques et politiques
qui lui sont associés
clairement si on veut avoir une chance
de garder rt en dessous de 1 or
confinement aussi il va nous falloir
invoqué des interventions beaucoup plus
radical encore
êtes vous prêt à faire le nécessaire
pour nous épargner tout risque de
catastrophe planétaire
alors aujourd'hui j'ai insisté beaucoup
sur les problèmes plutôt que les
solutions notamment car estimer
l'efficacité des solutions proposées est
un problème très difficile en soi et
donc je préfère leur dédier tout un
épisode que j'essaie de sortir dès que
possible
comme l'expliquent cet article il n'y a
pas de plan pour revenir à la normale
des concessions énormes devront être
faites pour comprendre ces concessions
la prochaine fois on parlera notamment
beaucoup de cette équation là en
particulier cette équation suggère
l'importance du contact racing est en
gros dans la prochaine vidéo
j'essaierai de vous convaincre que sans
adoption massive du contact racing on
est probablement voué un second
confinement ou en tout cas des mesures
extrêmement contraignante pour les
libertés individuelles et pour notre
économie et enfin dans une troisième
vidéo
je défendrai une application appelée dp3
t qui me semble être un bon compromis
entre efficacité et protection de la vie
privée
mais avant de parler de cette solution
il me semblait important d'insister
beaucoup sur les risques auxquels
l'humanité est désormais confronté il me
semble malheureusement très probable que
le pire soit encore à venir
que sera-t-il malheureusement à l'heure
actuelle il ya encore énormément de
scénarios futurs possibles
l'incertitude est énorme dans ce
contexte il est crucial de prêter
attention à notre excès de confiance et
de se demander si des scénarios qui nous
paraissent farfelus sont vraiment
suffisamment improbable pour être
complètement exclu mais surtout si ces
scénarios ne sont pas suffisamment
improbable si leur probabilité excède
disons 1%
il semble alors crucial de se demander
comment éviter une telle probabilité de
catastrophe
il est urgent d'adopter le celtix mate 7
et d'envisager beaucoup plus
sérieusement des pires cas même si ces
derniers ne sont pas les scénarios les
plus probables
plus que jamais il est urgent de
raisonner de manière probable east est
de faire de notre mieux pour réduire les
probabilités de catastrophes futures